a typical day for a maths teacher like
me is that I come in nice and early have
a think about what lessons are coming up
what assessments and big events are
happening in the calendar of my faculty
as a head teacher and once I've got my
hair in the right space I have a look at
one of the what are the urgent tasks
that identified the day before that I
can just get started on get straight
into them the day begins
I might have three or four five lessons
and going between them because all of
the planning has been done I just really
like to make sure that I bring energy to
my classroom I think it's the most
valuable thing I can have it's all
prepared I just like to kind of let
unfurl and to let all of those
conversations and surprising moments
unfold in the classroom angles read
pretty girls they have it right just
like to study mathematics is really to
be able to get a hold of like what's
reality made of like you know we we walk
along the ground and we don't race off
into the air because gravity these
mathematical laws are holding us to the
ground and when we want to understand
you know the world around us you look at
a flower and you look at the number of
petals that are there or the shape of
all of the little seeds on it and all of
that mathematical so for me I just get
so much enjoyment then we learn from
being able to talk about such an
interesting thing all day but I also
love seeing you when a student has a
really hard movement when there's some
insight that they they just couldn't
wrap their heads around and suddenly you
know we talked and we questioned we go
round and round around and we draw
things and suddenly it clicks and I can
literally see that moment and their eyes
kind of widen a little bit and they say
I get it I get it sir and that moment is
priceless and I get to see it every day
and it's kind of addictive for students
to have that experience and for me to
have the privilege to help them get that
themselves
I just wouldn't trade it for anything
teaching is a really really tiring job
because we're all on our feet but it's
so rewarding when you think back to what
did you just expand all your energy on
and you can talk about that moment you
have with a student where you got them
to see this really really crucial
insight or a student's work that was
just amazing and you had no idea they
were capable of that kind of quality and
you just get to share those stories and
is a really nice way to cap off the day
and be able to go home and say that's
why I come to work each day